and that's it from new york for the
washington journal
[Music]
[Music]
this is the vietnam wall on the national
mall in washington dc
thousands of veterans their families and
friends have been visiting the monument
this week as the country looks back on
the 25th anniversary of the fall of
saigon
c-span is also looking back today at the
vietnam war
what led to it how it unfolded and what
has happened since
you'll hear from major players from the
era including president gerald ford and
former senator eugene mccarthy
we'll also show you an interview we did
with senator john mccain back in 1992 as
he reflected on his years as a prisoner
of war in hanoi
that's all coming up this afternoon
we're going to begin with a news
conference from april 29 1975
president ford's press secretary ron
nessen and then secretary of state henry
kissinger make statements on the fall of
saigon and they answer questions from
reporters
this 30-minute tape was provided to us
by nbc news
the briefing was delayed until the
evacuation was completed
and the last helicopters are now in the
air
i'd like to read a statement by the
president
during the past week the president had
ordered the reduction of american
personnel in the united states mission
in saigon
to levels that could be quickly
evacuated during during an emergency
while enabling that mission to continue
to fulfill its duties
during the day on monday washington time
the airport in saigon came under
persistent rocket as well as artillery
fire and was effectively closed the
military situation in the area
deteriorated rapidly
the president therefore ordered the
evacuation of all american personnel
remaining in south vietnam
the evacuation has now been completed
the president commends the personnel of
the armed forces who accomplished it
as well as ambassador graham martin and
the staff of his mission who served so
well under difficult conditions
this action closes a chapter in the
american experience
the president asks all americans to
close ranks
to avoid recriminations about the past
to look ahead to the many goals we share
and to work together on the great tasks
that remain to be accomplished
copies of this statement will be
available as you leave the briefing
now to give you details of the events of
the past few days and to answer your
questions
secretary of state kissinger
ladies and gentlemen
when
the president
spoke
before the congress
he uh stated as our objective
the
stabilization of the situation in
vietnam
we made clear at that time
as well as
before
many congressional hearings
that
our purpose was
to bring about the most controlled
and the most humane
solution that was possible
and that our objectives
required
and that these objectives required the
cause which the president had said
our
priorities were as follows
we sought to save
the american lives
in still in vietnam
we tried to rescue
as many
south vietnamese
that had worked with the united states
for 15 years
in reliance on our commitments
as we possibly could
and we sought
to bring about
as humane
an outcome
as was achievable under the conditions
that
existed
over the past
two weeks
the american personnel in vietnam has
been progressively reduced
our objective was to reduce at a rate
that was significant enough
so that we would finally be able to
evacuate
rapidly but which would not produce a
panic which might prevent
anybody from getting out
our objective was also
to
fulfill
the human obligation
which we felt to the tens of thousands
of south vietnamese
who had worked with us
for over a decade
and finally we sought
through various intermediaries
to bring about
as
humane a political evolution as we could
by sunday evening the personnel in our
mission
had been reduced to nine to nine hundred
and fifty
and there were eight thousand south
vietnamese
that we considered in a particularly
high risk category between five and
eight thousand we don't know the exact
number
on monday evening
washington time around five o'clock
which is uh which was tuesday morning
in saigon
the airport in tanzania was
rocketed
and received artillery fire
president called an nsc meeting
he decided that if the shelling stopped
by dawn uh saigon time
we would attempt to operate with
fixed-wing aircraft from tanzania
airport for one more day
to remove the high-risk
south vietnamese
together with all the defense attaches
office which was located near the tent
near the tanzanite airport
he also ordered a substantial reduction
of the remaining american personnel
in south vietnam
i must point out i may point out that
that the american personnel in saigon
was divided into two groups
one with the defense attaches office
which was located near the tanzania
airport
the second one uh which was uh related
to the embassy and was with the united
states mission in downtown cycle
uh the shelling did stop early in the
morning on tuesday
saigon time or about nine o'clock
nine pm
last night washing time
we then attempted to land
uh c-130s
but found that the uh
that the population at the airport
had got uh out of control and had
flooded the runways and it proved
impossible to land any more fixed-wing
aircraft
the president thereupon ordered that the
d.a.o personnel
together with those civilians that
had been made ready
to laugh to be evacuated we moved to the
d.a.o compound
which is near tanzanite airport
and about 11 o'clock last night
he ordered the uh
evacuation
of all americans
from uh
from tanzania
and from
the embassy as well
this has
this operation has been going on all day
which
of course is night
in saigon
under difficult uh circumstances
and the total number of those evacuated
numbers about 6500
uh we will have the exact figures for
you tomorrow
of which about a thousand
are americans
our ambassador uh left
has left and the evacuation can be said
to be uh
can be said to be completed
in the period since the president spoke
to the congress
we have
therefore succeeded
in evacuating all of the americans who
were in
south vietnam
losing only
losing the two marines who were
last night to rocket fire
and two pilots uh today on a helicopter
uh we
succeeded in evacuating some something
on the order of 55 000
south vietnamese
and we hope that we have contributed
to a political evolution
that may spare the south vietnam some of
the more drastic consequences
of
a political change
but this remains to be seen this last
point remains to be seen
as far as the administration is
concerned
i can only underline the point made by
the president
we
do not believe
that this is a time for recrimination
it is a time to heal wounds
to look at
our international obligations
and to remember
that peace and progress in the world
has depended importantly
on american commitments
and american
convictions
and that
the peace
and progress of our own people
is closely tied to that of the rest of
the world
i'll be glad to answer your questions
you made some reference a few weeks back
uh to those who believe in the domino
theory and while i don't remember
exactly your words the point was it's
easy to laugh at it but there is some
justification for subscribing to that
theory now that this chapter is over can
you give us our estimate of the security
of thailand
and other countries
to
manage and to
and to
progress
along the road towards uh
a permanent piece that we have sought
but there's no question but that there
will be consequences peter
could you tell us or elaborate
in more detail what we did through
various intermediaries to bring about i
think you said as humane a political
solution as possible
and why those efforts seem to have
failed
well i would not agree with the
proposition that these efforts uh have
failed
because at least
some uh some of the efforts uh
especially those related uh to
evacuation
uh
were uh
were carried out uh were carried out uh
through intermediaries
we dealt with
i think it is premature for me to go
into all of the details
but
we did deal with hanoi
and
with the prg through different
intermediaries
and we uh
we're in a position to put our views
and receive responses
by saying why then was it necessary to
stage a rescue operation
at the in the final stage well in the
final stages it was always foreseen
that a uh
a helicopter lift for
some contingent would be necessary i
believe that the dynamics of the
situation in south vietnam
and the uh
impatience of the north vietnamese to to
seize power
brought about an acceleration of events
in the last
in the last
day and a half
but
you will remember there was a period of
about five days
when both civilian and uh
and u.s personnel
were evacuated without any uh
substantial opposition in fact more than
five days about a week
on that point uh
uh do you now anticipate that the north
vietnamese intend to move in and
forcefully seize saigon do you
anticipate that there will be a
bloody battle of saigon
or
will is there still a chance for an
orderly transition
uh it's this is very difficult to judge
at this moment
i think it's important to point out
that the communist demands have been
escalating
as the military situation has changed in
their favor
a week ago they were asking only for the
removal of president chu
uh when he resigned
they immediately asked for the removal
of his successor specifying that
general min would be acceptable when uh
president huang resigned in favor of
general min he was now described as a
member of a clique which lists which
includes all of the members of his
administration
a week ago it
uh the
communist demand was for the removal of
american military personnel
this quickly escalated into removal of
all american personnel
then a new demand was put forward for
the uh dismantling
of the south vietnamese military
apparatus
when that was agreed to
they added to it the demand for the
dismantling of the south vietnamese
administrative apparatus
so
uh it is clear that what is being aimed
at is a substantial political takeover
now whether it is possible to avoid a
battle for saigon
uh it is too early to judge i would hope
and we certainly have attempted to
work in that direction
that such a battle can be avoided and it
is basically unnecessary because it
seems to us that the south vietnamese
government is prepared to draw the
conclusions
uh from the existing situation and in
fact was formed to correspond to the
demands of the communist side
secretary do you consider the united
states now
uh
it owes any any allegiance at all to the
paris factory now are we now bound in
any way by the paris agreements
well uh as far as the united states is
concerned
there aren't many provisions of the
paris agreement that are still
relevant
uh as far as the north vietnamese are
concerned they have stated that they
would like to that they
wish to carry out
the paris accord though by what
definition is not fully clear to me
we would certainly uh support this
if it has any meaning i ask one
follow-up
do you now favor
a uh american aide in the rebuilding of
north vietnam
uh
i consider no i do not favor american
aid for rebuilding north vietnam
well with respect to south vietnam we
will have to see what
uh
kind of government emerges and indeed
whether there's going to be a south
vietnam
uh
we
would certainly look at particular
specific humanitarian requests that can
be carried out by uh
by humanitarian agencies but we do
believe that the primary responsibility
should fall on
those who supplied the weapons for this
political
i'd like to ask a change about the
length of time that it took to complete
this evacuation yeah first the question
of whether
days went by after the end became
obvious before ordering the evacuation
second if after ordering it there was a
one-hour delay in helicopter landings
apparently caused by military confusion
third whether the evacuation was
prolonged
by picking up thousands of vietnamese
instead of concentrating on americans
and
fourth whether this was delayed even
further by ambassador martin's desire to
be the last man to leave the sinking
ship
in other words i i tried to put the
specifics in in order to ask you
did it take too long to get out of there
to write this last chapter
we got we got out
by uh
with all of
the personnel
that was there
without
without panic and without uh
the substantial uh
casualties that could have occurred
if civil order had totally broken down
we also managed to save 56 000 people
whose life was in the most severe
jeopardy
and
we
had to make a judgment
every day
how many people we thought we could
safely remove
without triggering a panic
and at the same time still be able to
carry out
our principal function
and the remaining functions
i think these objectives were achieved
and they were carried out successfully
and therefore i do not believe that
there was an undue delay
uh because an evacuation has been going
on for two weeks
the difference between the last stage
and the previous period was that the
last stage was done by
by helicopter
and the previous
stage had been done by fixed wing
uh
and
i think the ability to conduct the final
evacuation
uh by helicopter without casualties
during the operation
when at least casualties caused by
hostile action
is closely related to the uh
policies that were pursued in the
preceding
in the preceding two weeks
as for ambassador martin
he was in a very difficult position
uh he uh
he felt a moral obligation to the people
with whom he had been associated
and he attempted to save as many of
those as possible
uh and
that's not the worst ball the man can
have
there's been numerous reports of
american appeals to the soviets to the
chinese can you say today in the
evacuation effort where the
either the soviets or the chinese
helpful or unhelpful in this uh
diplomatic effort
uh
i think that
we received some help
from uh the soviet union in uh in the
evacuation effort
the degree of it uh we will
have to assess
when we study the exchanges
dr
what caused the breakdown of the attempt
which was spoken of earlier on the hill
to try to achieve a measure of
self-determination to the people of
south vietnam
and what is your total assessment now of
the
effectiveness of the non-effectiveness
of the whole paris support operation
which you said
at the outset uh was intended to achieve
peace with honor for the united states
the uh
until
until sunday night
we thought there was some
considerable hope
that
the north vietnamese would not seek a
solution by purely military means
and
when
the transfer of power to general min
took place
a person who had been designated by the
other side
as in as a counterpart
worth talking to who they would be
prepared to talk with
we thought that a negotiated solution
in the next few days
was highly profitable
sometime
sunday night
the north vietnamese obviously changed
signals
why that is we do not yet know
and nor do i exclude that now that the
american presence is totally removed
and uh
very little military structure is left
in south vietnam that there may not be
a sort of a negotiation
but what
uh what produced this
sudden shift to a military option
or what to seem to has to be a sudden
shift to a military option
i have not had a sufficient opportunity
to analyze
now as to the effectiveness of the paris
accords
i think it is important to remember
the mood in this country
uh at the time that the paris accords
were being negotiated
now i think it is worth remembering
that the principal criticism that was
then made
was that the terms we insisted on
uh were
were too tough
not that the terms
were too generous
we wanted what was considered peace with
honor was that the united states would
not end a war
by
overthrowing
a government with which it had been
associated
and
that still
seems like
uh an objective
that
that was correct
now there were several other assumptions
that were made at that time
that were later
falsified by events
that were beyond the control of and that
were indeed unforeseeable
by anybody who negotiated these
agreements
including the
disintegration of
uh
or the weakening of executive authority
in the united states
for reasons unconnected with foreign
policy considerations
so the premises of the paris occurred
in terms of aid of the possibility of
aid and in terms of other factors tended
to
[Music]
tended to disintegrate
i see no purpose now in
in reviewing that particular history
within the context of the time
uh
it seemed
the right thing to do
what is our what is the current
relationship of the united states
to the south vietnamese uh uh political
uh
grouping or whatever you would call it
we will have to we will have to see what
grouping emerges out of these [ __ ] out
of
whatever negotiations should now take
place
between the two south vietnamese sides
after we have seen what grouping emerges
and what degree of independence it has
then we can make a decision about what
our political relationship to it is we
have not made a decision on that you say
diplomatic relations are in abeyance
with the government in south vietnam i
think that's a fair statement
looking back on the war now
would you say that the war was in vain
and what do you feel at a conference
i think it will be a long time
before
we can
before americans will be able to talk or
write about the war with some dispassion
it is clear
that the war did not achieve the
objectives
of those
who who
started the original involvement
noah the objectives of those who sought
to end that involvement which they found
uh on terms which uh seem to them
compatible with the sacrifices that had
been made
what lessons we should draw from it i
think we should reserve for for another
occasion
but i don't think
that we can solve the problem
of having entered
the conflict too lightly
by leaving it too lightly either
secretary
looking toward the future has america
been so stunned by the experience in
vietnam that it will never again come to
the military or economic aid of an ally
i'm talking specifically in the case of
israel
well as i uh pointed out in a speech
a few uh a few weeks ago
it is one lesson we must learn from this
experience
is that we must be very careful
in the commitments we make
but uh that we should scrupulously honor
those commitments we do make
i believe that the experience in the war
that the war has had
can make us
more mature
in the commitments we undertake
and more determined to maintain those we
have
uh
i would therefore think that
with relation
to other countries
including israel
that no lessons should be drawn by
the enemies of our friends
from the experiences in vietnam
view of the developments
in the last week or so would you agree
that
there was never any hope of stabilizing
the south vietnamese military situation
after with the withdrawal from the
northern regions
now when uh the president met with
general ryan in palm springs
uh the judgment was that there was a
slim hope
but
somehow
uh
not
somewhat less than 50 50 but
still
some hope
the situation deteriorated with every uh
with every passing day
now those of you
whom i briefed at that time will
remember
said i said that whatever and i said it
in public uh testimony on innumerable
locations
that whatever objective
we
may set ourselves and whatever
assessment we make about the outcome
the administration had no choice except
to pursue the cause that we did
which was designed to save the american
still in vietnam and the maximum number
of
vietnamese lives should the birth come
to pass
mr secretary two questions could you
tell us are you now reassessing the
amount of humanitarian aid you wish
congress to give to the south vietnamese
and also can you tell us the president's
reaction and moods during these past 24
hours
uh
with respect to humanitarian aid for
south vietnam
we spoke to the congressional leadership
this morning
and we urged them
uh to uh
to pass the humanitarian
part of the eight requests that we have
submitted to the countries
the president pointed out that he would
make a later decision
as to
as to
what
uh
part of that humanitarian aid
could be
used in south vietnam
after the political evolution in south
vietnam becomes becomes clearer
the president's mood
was
somber
and
undetermined
and
we all went through
a somewhat anxious 24 hours
because until the last helicopter had
left
we
couldn't really know
uh
whether an attack on any of these
compounds might start
and whether
missiles might be used against our
evacuation
mr secretary can i ask you to clarify
something that seems rather important at
this point you've said here and in the
past that a weakening of the american
executive authority
was a factor in this whole outcome
now there have been reports that former
president nixon with your advice had
decided in april of 1973
to resume the bombing of north vietnam
but the watergate intruded and he could
not carry through that is that a
historic fact or not
uh
to
to my uh
to the best of my knowledge
uh president nixon had never actually
decided
on any particular action
the
washington special action group at that
period
was considering
a number of reactions
uh that could be taken to
the beginning flagrant violations
of uh
of the of the of the agreements and this
was done on a on an interdepartmental
basis including the department of state
my office the department of defense
had reached certain options
then uh president nixon in the as it
turned out never made a final decision
between these options
uh to what extent that was influenced by
watergate
a psychological assessment that one
can only speculate about
there's a new asia developing
after the indo-china situation
what will the priorities of the united
states be in recognizing its existing
commitments and in making new ones
well
uh
we will have
to assess
the impact of indochina
on
uh
our allies and on other countries in
that area
and on their perceptions
of the united states
and we will have to
we will have to assess also
what role the united states can
responsibly play
over an indefinite period of time
because surely another lesson we should
draw from the indochina experience
is that a foreign policy must be
sustained
over decades
if
it is
to be effective
and if it cannot be
then it has to be tailored to what is
sustained
this is the vietnam wall here in
washington dc
it's become a focal point for veterans
their families and friends on this
anniversary weekend of the fall of
saigon
we continue our look back at the vietnam
war with a discussion organized by the
gerald ford library and museum
earlier this month the former president
hosted a day-long conference at the
university of michigan
on the long-term consequences of u.s
involvement in vietnam
first panel reflects on the war's impact
on u.s foreign policy in the 25 years
since the end of the war it features
former key policy advisers brent
scowcroft and lawrence eagleburger it
runs about an hour 45 minutes
but